and the voiceover work if someone wanted
to get started in that i mean what's the
best way to do that especially if
they've never done it before well
voiceover is
without a doubt the most competitive
competitive niche i think in
the entertainment business um there are
so many different
uh facets to it there are
you know there are commercial voiceovers
video games um
just all kinds of
components to the
the world of voice over animation the
world of voice over
the most important thing i think
a new person can do is to take a class
and learn how to do voiceover
doing voiceover is not about having a
voice like this
99 of the time it's about you know
and the flavor of the day changes
constantly
and you have to be adaptable to that and
go with that you have to be able to take
direction and learn how to
um say
a phrase in
99 shades of blue
you know
and being able to interpret copy and
uh is so important and you learn all
that in a voiceover class and there are
a number of
different good ones that are that are
being offered in los angeles at any
given time and then
and see you know some you might find
that it's not for you
um
but
give the class a shot to find out
whether or not you're you know this is
something you really want to pursue then
make yourself a demo
cd
and there are
people that produce demo cds as well a
mistake that a lot of new voice over
people make is to
move too quickly into making a demo
because demo producers can produce
something that sounds really
professional and slick
the problem is that if you don't have
the classroom experience
and the sort of semi-real-world
experience of working constantly in a
group situation in a class then you
won't be able to live up to that demo in
a real world studio situation
and
you're not going to do anybody any
favors by by doing that
so
you know everything occurs
in a specific order
and spend as much time as you need to on
each ingredient in the in the order
there and you make a demo and then you
shop your demo around to agents
and
voice over isn't really a hobby it's not
a part-time thing
you really sort of have to commit to it
as a full-time
endeavor if you really want to
have access to the auditions and to the
opportunities that come with voice-over
yeah
it's don it's daunting it's daunting but
the rewards are great